hush is directed by Mike Flanagan the
guy who brought us oculus a horror film
that I found very underrated this film
is currently available on Netflix
streaming so this author lives in a
cabin in the middle of the woods and
she's trying to write her book well
being stalked by somebody psychotic and
that kind of sounds like the movies
secret window with Johnny Depp which was
a very good movie but this movie has a
very interesting hook to hooks in fact
one of them being that this killer
doesn't want to come inside yet he just
wants to mess around with her for a
while he wants to play a sadistic game
with her and the other is that she's
mute and deaf so that is a big problem
so it's a clever twist on the home
invasion genre now we've seen something
like this before in a movie called wait
until dark starring Audrey Hepburn I
love that movie I grew up watching it it
came out in 1967 it's about a blind
woman whose home is being invaded by
three men who want something inside of
her house this movie is similar in
really just one way it's a woman who has
a perceived disability trying to defend
herself against someone who is invading
her home except it's a little bit
different and wait until dark these guys
wanted something from this woman because
it was theirs and it was accidentally
placed in her house and since she's
blind she didn't know about it in this
movie this guy's just a psycho and
rather than being blind she's deaf and
mute Plus once the movie really starts
and you get past the initial setup the
movies aren't really that similar I
thought this film was tons of fun I
thought it was a great thrill ride it's
very well acted there isn't something
about this movie that you watch and you
go oh my god my mind is blown because
it's not trying to be it's just trying
to be a really good thriller it's also
very well acted the man who plays the
killer I don't want to ruin it for you
because I personally didn't know going
in so if you don't know who plays the
killer just go watch it it's on Netflix
I hated this guy I hated him
I wanted this guy gone every time she
got just slightly ahead of him I was
like here ups like it was just such a
crowd-pleasing movie in some aspects
there's also a very good way the movie
toys with you sometimes she imagines
scenarios in her brain because she's
very smart she goes through what she
could possibly do and the movie tricks
you a few times and it really got to me
in fact one time I audibly went No good
job Mike Flanagan you had me
had me in your grip and that's what's
good about this movie it's a movie that
is just relentless in regards to being a
thriller it's simply a thriller
it's an 87 minute movie with a woman who
has a perceived disability and she has
to use her disability to her advantage
to try to figure out how to get out of
this situation while this crazy guys
outside and all of her technology is
gone she has no cell phone the power is
out and you have this one secluded
location and they make the best use of
it it also turns a lot of horror cliches
on end you expect certain things to
happen at some time and they don't
happen you expect certain jump scares to
happen and they don't happen it's such a
breath of fresh air to experience a fun
thriller I would relate this film to the
late Wes Craven's red eye
totally different movies but very
similar ideas very short films that are
contained in one location with a woman
in peril and you have to watch as she
cleverly figures out ways to get out of
these situations they're both not trying
to be anything more than what they are
they're just fun thrill rides also the
movie has some very chilling
implications with just little hints of
visual things like something etched into
this guy's crossbow really chilling
stuff really well acted and I was on the
edge of my seat I'm gonna give hush and
a - guys it's on Netflix right now go
check it out it's a lot of fun it's all
those movies where you want to scream of
your TV and just get so upset but watch
it in the dark I watched it in my
basement on my 65 inch TV in the dark
with two candles and it creeped me out
that's a really good idea I suggest
doing that guys you are the best thank
you so much for watching next week I'll
be back with a review for the jungle
book I'm looking forward to that if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck when iced